YEN-JIE LEE: So
during the class,
I usually do a little vote
on the physical situation
we are interested in
to predict what will be
the outcome of the calculation.
I think that is actually a very,
very interesting thing to do.
First of all, that will attract
the attention of the students
that we are going
to do a prediction
of a physical situation.
OK?
So that's actually
the first purpose,
to encourage participation
of the students into class.
And then secondly, I can know
if the majority of the students
already know the outcome or not
by looking at the vote result.
So if I have--
if I have my polarizer
orienting in this direction,
can you predict what will happen
to the readout on the scope?
Will I see signal or not?
How many of you actually
think we will see signal
if I arrange that?
The electromagnetic
wave is actually
pointing-- polarized in
the up and down direction.
OK, one, two--
OK, only four people think so.
How many of you think
nothing will change?
I'm sorry, nothing will
be observed by the scope.
OK, most of you
actually think so.
So let's actually really
do the experiment.
I choose to use an analog method
instead of clicker or support
with other technical tools.
And that is because I
would like this process
to be as smooth as
I could achieve.
So doing it by raising
your hand, first of all,
they have to do a lot
more by raising your hand
instead of clicking a button.
So that actually makes
a difference for them
to focus on my question.
OK.
So secondly, I don't want
to do a automatic counting
because usually,
they provide a graph,
and I have to switch back
and forth between graph
and my lectures or my
other lecture slides.
And that usually
takes some time.
And also, that
introduces interruptions
during my lecture.